No one did more to mainstream
libertarian ideas about peace, love
and understanding over the past half
century than P.J.
O'Rourke, who has died at
the age of 74.
And like Frank Sinatra, Elvis
Presley and Sid Vicious, P.J.
did it his way by taking
a blowtorch to the sacred cows
of both the left and right.
"The Democrats are the party that
says government will make you
smarter, taller, richer and remove
the crabgrass on your lawn," he
warned.
"The Republicans are the party that
says government doesn't work and
then they get elected and prove it."
Writing in popular outlets such as
National Lampoon, Rolling Stone and
The Atlantic, and appearing on shows
like NPR's Wait, Wait Don't Tell
Me, O'Rourke distilled the insights
of Milton Friedman, Ayn Rand and
Friedrich Hayek with far more oomph
than they could ever manage.
"Giving money and power to the
government is like giving whiskey
and car keys to teenage boys,"
wrote O'Rourke.
"When buying and selling are
controlled by legislation, the first
things to be bought and sold are
legislators." "Libertarianism
isn't political," he insisted.
"It's anti-political, really.
It wants to take things out of the
political arena." Like his
journalistic inspirations, Tom
Wolfe and Hunter S.
Thompson, O'Rourke was no armchair
curmudgeon or ivory-tower
philosopher king.
At his very best, in books like
All the Trouble in the World and
Holidays in Hell, he engaged the
world directly and often at great
personal risk, traveling to war
zones and disaster areas in more
than 40 countries, including urban
and rural hellholes in the United
States.
I have always
belonged to the pessimistic
wing of the libertarian
attitude.
This is probably because I spent 20
years as a foreign correspondent,
largely covering wars and
insurrections and social
upheavals and disturbances
of all sorts of ugly cons.
We have a rational side,
thank God.
But it isn't the only side
in our multifaceted
and sometimes pretty ugly little
personalities.
Even as he despaired over a
presidential contest between Joe
Biden and Donald Trump, he was never
dissuaded from his faith in
individuals yearning to be free,
whether they live in Chicago or
China. "At the core of
libertarianism, as an attitude
and as a way of thinking about
politics," he said, "is
the idea that people are assets."
His elegiac 2014
book, The Baby Boom: How It Got That
Way and It Wasn't My Fault and I'll
Never Do It Again, writes his
epitaph.
Far from being either a screed
against his own generation, which
is what he expected it to be when he
started writing, or an attack
on millennials, it was instead a
funny and thoughtful meditation
on how we've arrived at a kinder,
gentler country that somehow manages
to prize individualism and
community, innovation and
tradition.
When asked whether the fights
between the greatest generation
boomers and millennials had left the
country weirder and better off,
he told Reason, "I think so."
Certainly more tolerant.
In fact, tolerance isn't even a
good word anymore because tolerance
means, Well, I'll put up with you if
I have to, you know,
is more enthusiastic
about people's differences, you
know, applauding
them, embracing them, as it were.
And that's, that's good.
If that's true, it's in no small
part due to the contribution
O'Rourke offered up, first
by making us laugh, then
by making us think, and finally
by making us want to go out into
the world he traveled with such
passion.